GEMMA CHAN
The Eternals is definitely
a very ambitious film.
SERSI
It's beautiful, isn't it?
GEMMA CHAN
You've got 10 new characters.
It spans 7,000 years.
The scope and the scale of it is huge.
CHLOE ZHAO
What excites me the most
is the world building, and the design.
Jack Kirby's comics
are great inspirations.
KEVIN FEIGE
What we really wanted to do was
start fresh with whole new characters,
new storylines, but actually go back
to some of the deepest,
richest mythology in all of Marvel comics.
CHLOE ZHAO
Each of my cast come from different
backgrounds and they come
from different life experiences.
So I'm trying to see how much of
this character is already in this person.
NATE MOORE
Chloe Zhao really pressed us to shoot more
of this on practical locations,
which is challenging, but it's all
in service of an aesthetic
that's totally different.
IKARIS
You hear that? Eternals assemble.
KEVIN FEIGE
The impact that Eternals will have
on the MCU...
...will be nothing less than
redefining the cinematic universe entirely.